if makeup okay hold on okay we are in
ladies and gentlemen we are live it is
the ten de lijn show here again excited
to be with you
quarantine time here with Ben Avery the
producer we are here where are we at
what are our totals
please case totals and death totals
first okay let me get the totals first
we have uh we're gonna do totals in the
beginning of the show every show
coronavirus case is a hundred and eighty
two thousand six hundred nine right now
in the world one hundred eighty two
thousand cases 609 of the coronavirus
[Music]
7,107 a lot of actors it's a lot of
crisis actors some of them are pretty
good to keep going that's a joke it's
real
we have 7171 deaths okay what about in
America oh closer to home already
here we go let's go by country it's
important everybody that you subscribe
to the YouTube channel of Tim Dylan show
we do have the vaccine in the US right
now we have four thousand seven hundred
twelve cases 4712 case it seems to be
doubling every day does that mean
tomorrow we'll have eight thousand
possibly possibly yeah yeah it's a rough
one out there folks we're approaching a
hundred deaths were at ninety-one we're
about ninety one deaths we don't have a
hundred deaths yet five new deaths today
five new deaths today
mm-hmm but I'll tell you this much I do
we do have the vaccine I was [ __ ]
around today in the kitchen and we got
the vaccine we're excited about it we're
gonna sell it to you and we do have the
corona test kits so you can know if you
have corona we should have just had the
tests this whole thing could have been
avoided if we had the [ __ ] tests I
don't care if you love Trump he should
have gotten more tests we should have
had enough taxes this whole [ __ ]
thing is about the test it is that a
fireable offense probably you know if
that was your [ __ ] job
um Taiwan see how many cases Taiwan has
Taiwan is right next to [ __ ] China
this is a country that knew exactly what
to do immediately 67 cases one day 67
cases one death in [ __ ] Taiwan
because they had tests they closed
borders immediately which Trump did good
for him they have a very well-funded
high tech national or public health
service people got text messages of
their results they got texts of the
[ __ ] results in Taiwan that's why
they have 85 deaths I'm sorry yeah 85
cases one death one person here in
Taiwan died of this virus what's the
population of Taiwan one person in
TRUCKING Taiwan died of this virus 23.78
million 23.78 million people they had
one death from this [ __ ] virus
because they all put the masks on we all
make fun of the Asians with the masks on
all the time I do it all the time but
Taiwan immediately started with the
masks they closed the borders they had
tests available people got texted their
results they had to report to isolation
85 [ __ ] deaths I mean I'm sorry 85
cases one death in a country of 23
million people that's the that's the how
you want to handle it that's 30 Ortega
asks have either of you had chickenpox
yes I chicken pox as a child and I could
I had to stay home usually we had
Christmas and my grandfather's with all
the kids none of them had it yet so I
had to stay home that my grandfather and
my nanny brought me bags of presents to
my house to open which is very nice of
them nice yeah
people are just filing in here people
are filing in it's gonna take a while
here's what we're gonna do folks we ramp
it up we ramp it up our schedule we're
gonna do one live stream minimal a week
maybe two and then we're gonna do it and
then it's gonna go on our patreon as
well as other patreon episodes we're not
just gonna we're not just gonna do only
live scenes but the live streams if
they're not live they're going to
go on the patreon we may start putting
out emergency podcasts on our YouTube
channel as well little 30 minute 45
minute emergency podcasts little you
know having people on the show that have
information that might be pertinent to
you and your loved ones during this
difficult time you're gonna have to
start looking at people in your house
and go who are we gonna eat first it's
the reality folks tough times stock
market plunge 30 percent today I was the
three thousand points yeah dropped
people lost a lot of [ __ ] money it's
coming there's gonna be runs on the
banks civil unrest you know how it is
food shortages supply line breakdowns
thank god lot large sections of our
country have schizophrenia so they
believe this whole virus is because Tom
Hanks is being arrested for pedophilia
they believe this the whole virus is a
cover for a military operation where
they're gonna they're gonna arrest Obama
and the Pope thank God
many of our people have insulated
themselves from facts and reason yeah we
have large swaths of the country that
are schizophrenic we have to accept that
undiagnosed festering mental illness
brought on by the way by you know real
events by being overworked overtired
stressed-out anxious drugged up eating
poison and then realizing that yes the
elite do inhabit a secret world where
they do whatever the [ __ ] they want and
that most of what you've been fed is a
lie all of that together oh that's a
real Willie work a boat ride into the
abyss and then you're just kind of
babbling you're like walking around
babbling you have no idea what's
happening Ryan wants to know did you
cancer your California show in August
I'll drink cyanide Ryan nobody's doing
anything right now I don't think that
shows officially canceled but I'll tell
you this I was on the phone today with
my agent everybody has
sold everything through May and the
summer is anyone's best gas because
there are people that say that the peak
could be July June July
like our [ __ ] president today but the
stock market crashing tell everyone it
could be like this will all get shut up
lie don't say anything you can't be this
is the one time you're gonna choose to
be honest with the people now so what
you have is you have a situation where
although the show is still on the books
it is absolutely very possible that that
the weekend is either changed or move
depending on facts on the ground Ryan I
don't know she wanted robotics thanks
for the super chat said in San Francisco
we we ride and when we won baseball
games
if cities like oak like Oakland and
Baltimore got locked down how far will
the government go to enforce it I don't
know well I mean we'll be what we'll see
but I mean probably pretty far they have
the military I mean the cops in some of
these cities will just shoot you in the
face anyway for loitering right so I
mean if we gave them a reason I would
imagine they'd go pretty far Sean asks
have you seen the coronavirus challenge
these people deserve death yeah they're
licking toilet seats on Plains Jesus
Christ is that ask him if that's what
he's referring to I believe it is there
was a girl who licked a toilet seat on a
plane
how great would it be Korona only killed
seventeen-year-olds
only killed young Zoomers and
millennials and kept kept the boomers
I'm used to them I'm used to the Boomers
sure they have their issues but I'm used
to them now yeah people are looking
toilet yeah that's the new Corona
challenge licking a toilet seat on a
plane Jesus Wow all right we got some
more super chats here rail Bay tasks or
says rail bait nothing will get you
barter for food and medicine and a post
corona apocalypse economy like a
perfectly set stone yeah no and listen
this is something people have asked me
uh and I've been I've been I've been
steadfast in my instructions to the
people that have chosen to be a part of
what I consider a beautiful company and
the company is jewels by podcaster Tim
Doyle we are not closed we are
operational fully operational take four
orders put the orders in we have our
processors we are not shutting down our
office we are just pure Elling the [ __ ]
out of the out of our processor Kelly
we're wiping her down we're wiping her
old gash down with Lysol disinfectant
wipes and she's processing all these
orders she's typing him up getting them
and get him the headquarters so don't
worry about the future don't think about
the future think about the present and
the past Thank You chemical shed will we
hear from new york correspondent raymond
compass evening I need his Co Jeff oh we
will try to get ready to cup on the
phone he was smoking a cigarette the
other day I mean this is a man that just
doesn't care John William codling I
thank you said if you could give one
teacher from Holy Trinity there's a guy
that's a guy who's not as successful as
his name yeah like a John William
cobbling should be a very successful guy
and the fact that he's talking to me in
a YouTube live streaming proves that
he's not lived up to his name John
Williams codling if you could get one
teacher from Holy Trinity the corona who
would it be
Oh
I never like to miss ammon she wore
rubber shoes she taught English hobo she
was like oh you think you're so smart
cuz you use big words I'm like yeah
that's it that's all it is dummy that's
intelligence you ugly witch she's like
you think he says smocks use big words
as it gets English that's that's what
we're doing here yeah I am smart cuz I
use big words
you [ __ ] T to the Catholic school and
you drive a [ __ ] car you don't have any
[ __ ] money
your husband pays so all those teachers
had attitudes your husband's paid for
everything
it's Catholic school they didn't have
any money because they had to [ __ ]
keep paying hush money and all the kids
got doinked hobo blues clown says there
was an old toothless woman sitting
outside the grocery store coughing
toward the entrance here in Phoenix do
we euthanize the homeless great question
and even before coronavirus the answer
was yes no you don't euthanize a
homeless you you got to get him inside
places and test him that's why we should
have tests you gotta test the homeless
someone super chatted please rail
against a OC and say your thought on her
this is food for my soul you know it was
a cool thing a rail on her and I don't
like her I get it my spidey senses go
off when she starts talking I think
she's insincere I think she is you know
just the idea that she refused to
campaign for Bernie Sanders you know
because she didn't like them the
endorsement of a podcast host to me
shows her true colors because if it
really is dire and Trump's really Hitler
and everybody's dot you know then the
fact that she's not showing up for
Sanders means that she's insincere I've
always thought she's insincere she's a
you know she's a politician like
everybody else she's full of [ __ ] she'll
be on the board of chase-manhattan soon
will trump send corn seem police for
opponents for opponents I don't even
understand what that means
me neither for like job I know which
city will be the first riot in the
country great question which city will
be the first riot
I don't know man New York is looking bad
I tend to think it's gonna be where it
gets the worst but I don't know
New York is looking pretty rough right
now okay guys a lot of super chats
coming in I'm gonna answer the ones that
are like five dollars and up right now
yeah we're doing five dollars in up
super chat you're not getting your
question answered for 99 cents take that
money and shove it up your ass this is
the end times right now what conspiracy
theory you spend to them beyond you
can't go out what conspiracy theories
seem plausible with this virus
where are the funerals IO weapon that
it's a bio weapon is plausible let it
let it leak that what I mean where are
the few what you mean where are the
funerals they can't hold funerals dummy
what do you you weren't invited to an
Italian funeral like what would be where
are the funerals do you believe that the
people in the hospital or actors do you
believe that all the people in Italy in
their homes are actors right do you
believe that my personal people that I
know personally that you know no people
in Italy I don't know anyone from Italy
but you tell me Andrew Schultz was a
Christmas ever knew was a comedian
friend in Italy that left him a
voicemail are all of these people actors
I mean where are the funerals guys what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I mean 150,000 people die in the world
every day you'd never see a funeral what
you know I mean it's just why does
everything have to be a conspiracy why
does it make you feel better at night
then everything say does it make you
feel better that you don't have a job
you want I mean literally what is it is
it do you go to bed at night going I
blew that job interview but you know
what it could economize like with knives
in the Staples Center to the death who
do I bet my MREs on Cruz okay when does
it a Scientologist yeah don't they'll
help them London Smith asks do you think
Bugsy Singh will be a thing with the
coronavirus and the elderly community
hilarious yes well people go and try to
get or give corona to the elderly I
don't know that sounds sick and fun and
II said giving you USD since it will
soon be worthless thank you but uh okay
great show happy to hear about more live
shows stay safe and healthy thank you
Anglophile dave says my Butler is
coughing do I burn his body on the
tennis court or just dump him in the
wood chipper I mean the help has to be
dealt with severely during this time
that's the reality I mean that's the
[ __ ] reality if somebody's late with
a postmates order I coughed right in her
face Sean says I heard Joe Rogan's his
dad is this true no he's alive
spoke to him today's alive okay Daniel
Charney do you think a second Trump win
would break people's minds so much we
would enter another period of escapist
surrealist art I tend to think the
pandemic and the mass graves will do
that Sean I tend to think that's gonna
be the more traumatizing thing to be
honest and if art's gonna come out of
anything is probably gonna become from
the millions of dead and the crash in
global economy civil unrest and you know
okay it's never been done before folks
you gotta realize this no one's ever
been told to just go home for two months
it's never happened before ever anywhere
really I mean just a massive shutdown
like this this is a psychological
experiment as much as its anything so
you're gonna see relationships go
through a lot you can see people go
through a lot psychologically that just
[ __ ] aren't outside they're not with
other people they're not connecting you
know with other people everybody's just
gonna connect digitally it's a [ __ ]
what you know it is gonna be a real
strain and it's an experiment and an
experiment that could go very wrong
Thiago Moniz says when all the Boomers
dies should I plan to buy a new home
when home prices tanked and rent my
current house or just sell my home and
not be a landlord
I mean rent your house this whole
landlord thing is landlords aren't evil
I mean I mean they're certainly Lords
can be evil but I mean this is that [ __ ]
this is why like Bernie got 20% of the
vote cuz you morons can't just go we
need health care you gotta feel like
landlords Remo nationalize the bank's
fight nobody should have any money
except my mom like guys enough with that
you know what the [ __ ] you think is
gonna have you think anybody has
patience for you you're [ __ ]
you're izing at this exact moment we're
in a [ __ ] people are gonna stab you
in the face very soon okay
Bernie's up there taught and I like
Bernie but he's something talking about
climate change we need climate change I
hope that the earth gets baked in April
till November and we could slow the
transmission of this [ __ ] thing
you're talking about student debt no one
has a job I like him he's got he's got
great messages but again enough you guys
go overboard all the time I talked to
people on the left and I just go to
karana and that little spiky guy and I
go you're the answer it's true I mean
we're living in a country where we eat
you know do we deserve a future I mean
if we were on a game show yeah and they
said do we deserve a future I'm sorry
but we would not win that the answer
would not be yes survey says no does it
make me happy I'd like a future we might
have one anyway we get a lot of [ __ ] we
don't deserve keep going Jake Bennet
asks will you be attending Coachella in
October yes I am I am on I'm on tour
with post Malone and um those are cat
and little grumpy yes we are keeping the
live streams on patreon yeah is gonna be
a patreon and I'm going on tour with
little grumpy okay Matthew Hart asks we
have 15 confirmed cases in Albany can
you give me a guest spot at the funny
bone I don't know if that's happening
the funny bone probably won't be listen
these clubs are going out of business
folks they're going out of business I
gotta I was on the phone owners today
they don't know if they can weather this
storm
I mean treat your local comedy clubs
well I don't even know what that means
in this particular moment but when and
if they do get up and run and go and buy
tickets cuz it's gonna be [ __ ] brutal
for a long time including that's
including restaurants and bars yeah
David Carpenter bars will be fine
because people will they won't be fine
the bars you know people are gonna go
and get hammered immediately but you
know other things might be slower to
come back
David Carpenter asks have you seen that
Chinese officials are starting to say
that the virus didn't originate in China
and are accusing the USA of planting the
virus what does this go yes I've seen
that I don't know I mean I don't trust a
Chinese not a trusty Americans it's Game
of Thrones there's no good guys I don't
know I have no idea I'm wondering if I
can get money out of the bank tomorrow
like that's where I'm at where did the
virus kyv no idea no clue do you know
tell me it might have came from a wet
market in China where they're eating
bats and pangolins and all that [ __ ]
they do that they've been doing that for
years however you know these viruses
show up into humans a lot they don't
always catch but could this have been
engineered to a degree 100% a hundred
percent
Alex was telling me about something
where they said that there was a guy
figured out how to put coronaviruses in
humans and stuff yeah so yeah yeah could
have easily originated somewhere that
nobody wants you to know yeah hunter
McClure asks is miss Maxwell in a corona
bunker where in the world interesting
question does jazz lane Maxwell have
Corona oh wow that's just laying off
Corona she calls up she's like Hello
well you know just lame I don't know I
told you where I thought she was Israel
I don't know is she gonna crawl a bunker
probably got a lot of rich friends with
Tiger Genesis asks Pennsylvania
government employees were telethon
there they were told Friday we're off
for two weeks now have to return
tomorrow no masks allowed by the way are
the jewels held up a do to the corona no
jewels and I've said this before there's
nothing no holdups with the jewels the
customers receive the jewels exactly
when they are meant to you know and when
you sell someone on a special experience
you don't talk about dates you talk
about an experience you sell an
experience
I asked me a question when the jewels
are coming where are the jewels coming
Tim when they get there it's gonna be
the greatest day of your life that's the
answer
Thank You Joseph for the super chat he
said just thanks for being you
those nice hey Joseph thank you how much
did he get 20 20 bucks Joseph we
appreciate that and that will be we're
donating all of the money that we get in
the Super chats to a new restaurant
that's being very stigmatized and it's
it's it's they're trying to come to
America and it's a chain of that it's
like a Chipotle but with bat it's all
bat products so we're donating it to
them because they've had a real rough
time the last couple of months
Michael ackley our Rothschild patreon
members welcome in your bunker please
send the coordinates no actual
Rothschilds are no $20 a month doesn't
get you room in a bunker I don't have a
bunker I know people that might have
bunkers but I'm not getting in the
bunker
Vladimir asks would love to see you and
Bobby Lee on the same podcast I think
it's worth getting corona for a sick
podcast yeah that'll happen soon we're
talking about that Adam asks is G
Jinping going the dictator or the States
you mean the president of China is he
what what's the question going the
dictator or the state's see the dictator
are we the dictator is he gone I don't
know he's a dictator are we gonna become
is this can also going into the people
anymore then then it's just a battle of
rich people trying to see who's gonna
rule us and the Trump's in there until
somebody with more money or power or
gets a foothold the military gets him
out of there I mean you know you see the
way that works in a lot of other
countries and the peaceful transfer of
power ends and you know there's probably
at that point homegrown resistance
movements to start to you know I mean it
gets really ugly really quick so you
hope that doesn't happen you hope for no
martial law and you hope that's why in
two or three months we gotta go outside
you got to go back to work yes people
are gonna get sick but we got to go back
to work you can't shut down an entire
country for six months it's not gonna
work not America it's not gonna work
so I think that this is gonna get better
everyone says it's gonna get worse
before it's gonna get better which I
agree with but I think it's all good
it's also gonna get better
eventually and I die I think there's too
much doom and gloom right now and that's
me saying that I'm I uhm the doom and
gloom territory but I think a lot of
comedians gotta stop getting and get off
Instagram lives nobody gives a [ __ ]
about what you say you're [ __ ] you're
disgusting get out of here you're
embarrassing yourself go home go with
your parents apologize to them and go
back to Community College in the fall
even if you're in your early 40s it
doesn't matter it's over the game is
over now sorry anyway those are the
subway the other day it's over now 91
Oki asks are you wearing your life in
the big city shirt titanium with bottle
opener Ridge wallet and went from Skull
and Bones to rotschild please tell me
you're going to skank fest is he a
[ __ ] ask him if he's a [ __ ] are you
a [ __ ]
there is no skank fest dummy it's over
what are you talking about it's over
everything's canceled does he mean the
one in New York City in like July maybe
or the one in Houston there is no one
and he might happen in July it might not
I don't know Sean says how did Q miss
this one yeah good question
rail bait asks once New York City curfew
is instated Jeff app can visit the
still-standing towers would you give him
one of your bus tours and you know what
I wouldn't I think he'd enjoy yeah I
think he'd really appreciate it and I
think he'd like it that's the thing
about Jeffrey Epstein you're probably
gonna hate this he was probably a lovely
guy I just person a person he was
probably lovely you know was he fun if
you were a 14 year old girl no no but
interactions interpersonally he was
probably probably nice guy yeah he was
getting all his needs met okay that's to
say it you know Dustin Dumas says look
up human resonance Earth's frequency and
why is it spiking will you do that
no ID we're not I mean I don't why don't
you just tell us Dustin
why am i what you know the answer ready
you thought it's interesting so why not
[ __ ] tell us what's happening instead
of telling us to look it up why we can't
pause the stream to look up why don't
you tell us what it is you know what it
is I hate when people do that hey you
know what you should look up no you'd
already did you tell me what's happened
Madison says my husband and I live in
Seattle should we end it now or attempt
an escape to Canada in parentheses
thanks for the laughs during in times I
want to ask her what's it what's going
on up there in Seattle I want to know
what's going on in Seattle Madison let
us know what's going on see I don't let
us know what's going on in Seattle we
have we have a friend who's inert or my
friend my friend has a friend who's a
nurse at Portland General or something
whatever it is whatever the hospital is
out there and we want to know what's
happened in Seattle because that's a
real hotbed how many cases in Seattle
man it's a real rough one up there in
Pacific Northwest it's real bad
Starbucks won't save you I think they're
going by County right now but let's see
what we can find it's really bad up
there in Seattle and Portland that's
what I've been hearing
shoutout to everybody in the Pacific
Northwest and not 905 905 cases not good
not good Souls reached 50 yeah 50 people
have died 900 cases they're gonna hit a
thousand verse and then if it happens
like they say it happens it's a thousand
a 2,000 that 4,000 and 8,000 in a double
I mean I hope that's not the case but
hopefully the social distancing is
working chemical shared thanks for the
nice super chat what my acute chemical
shed is chemical shed you yang gay guy
is it a reference to the largest LSD
operation in the country that was
operating out of a missile silo and kick
that is because podcasting zowie
remaining functional economy it's nrt 20
tonari 20 you have nothing to say thank
you for the super chat thank you for the
super chat it's not the mic folks 91 Oki
asks are you a negative blood type how
much is this I don't even know what I am
I literally don't know what blood type
man how much this is my cost like
$400 guns cheaper I don't know what
blood type I am like a b- and all that I
don't know what oh I know always the
most common I genuinely don't know what
I am
I could ask I'm I could find out I just
had blood work done everything came back
good but I don't know what blood type I
am I don't even know how to find that
out
is it on your driver's license hey is it
it might be I don't know river styxx
thanks for the super chat can this be
China's first major move to become the
world's biggest superpower the same way
America did in early 1900s with what the
smallpox blankets or something what do
you completely mean what do you mean by
that um could this be China's move to
what tanking their economy tanking their
economy and and I mean I understand what
you're saying like if they if they [ __ ]
over the whole world I mean China
militarily is not close to us their
economy is already larger than ours
officially but it's drastically been cut
I don't I don't buy that it this is a
move I don't buy that it's a play see
what you guys gonna realize about the
rich elites the lizard's the system
works well for them
it works well they like their sushi
restaurants they like their paedophile
Islands they like their mansions their
chalets and Aspen there's mean they like
being able to buy and blackmail
politicians and kill them if they really
think they're independent they've
arranged this world so that it works
very well for them they don't need to
tank all the money they don't want
people home reading on the internet
about all the fucked-up [ __ ] they've
been doing they want you working they
want you making pennies on the dollar at
Popeyes trust me they want somebody
handed them a hotdog in an edematous
idiom this whole thing that this is a
move this is a I just accept that
there's some random nature to life here
guys [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens I mean I
don't understand why that's so hard to
believe
okay proto noah asks how can we actually
convince you to get on only fans before
the world ends you would profit more
being a total nut sleeve than just a
great comedian yeah but I don't want to
be a total nut sleeve I mean that's the
whole thing yeah I don't want to be that
I don't you know I want to be funny and
I want to be what I'm being
dustin williams says i don't know what
is only fans by the way it's where you
post like nudes and people can pay for
the nudes yeah I don't um I don't
understand why going completely crazy is
to move yeah you know but again he's
probably skits if like there's a lot of
schizophrenic sat there that are just
we've we've the thing is with our people
this is what the rich have done and the
rich deserve it because they've ignored
people like that guy and they've let
them fester yeah to a point where
they're they're broken they're broken
toys so a lot of people in the country
are broken toys and he can't put them
back together again and it's gonna you
know the rich deserve it when these
people start going nuts okay Dustin
Williams asks what do you think it will
really take to break this 40-year
neoliberal pipe dream is there hope or
are we doomed to the conservative
autocratic boot
I mean imagine typing that into YouTube
I mean imagine imagine typing that into
YouTube um I don't know I mean again I
you like what do you mean the the
autocrat like uh-oh what do you think
the society is gonna look like you know
like uh is it reasonable to believe that
society will get more progressive as
things come and maybe yeah as younger
people vote you know that this is a
possibility but the American Empire is
not gonna look I don't know what you
think it's gonna look I don't know why
you think it is what it I don't know why
you think you have a home
yeah why do you think you have a house
and a home and like why do you think
this we've gotten to the level we've
gotten to and how do you think you
unwind this all without straight of
chaos like this whole neoliberal thing I
understand what you mean but we're an
empire and we're here for a reason it's
like you want to unwind it what do you
think you're gonna get you're not gonna
unwind it with that massive bloodshed
and a real problem yeah
so when you say like oh there's
neoliberal it's like yeah but I mean you
know what do you think's coming after
this take some goods come you think else
he's gonna show me housing [ __ ] yeah
and then you you and her can go get
tested together cuz your mouth ensure
like what do you think this the neck
fazer this it's not good I mean these
people living like a [ __ ] this is
like the people at Enron at the end of
and rounding like do you think will ever
be a good company can can can do you
think we'll ever just tell the truth
it's like [ __ ] why do you think we have
the office dummy we'll jump out of
windows how [ __ ] stupid are you
people God do you think we'll ever just
be an honest company and Ron I just want
to be proud to work here again wise we
told people we could sell weather no
it's not going back the other way next
okay we have a bunch of super chats here
guys we're we're gonna try to get to all
of them yeah we're gonna get to all of
them
okay we're pretty behind here how do we
punish the Chinese for this how do we
punish the Chinese for this make them
watch The Tonight Show Jimmy Fallon I'm
what I'm waiting to hear the argument
nathan fink asks what do you say to
parents who want to travel during this
crisis before you tell me to cancel them
they believe Epstein was murdered I
don't know who cared listen let people
do what they want it gives a [ __ ] what
they do listen if your parents want to
travel turn the crisis they're like the
stupidest people ever yeah cuz it's not
gonna even be fun T Dempsey ass should I
buy a handgun and will I have to eat the
squirrels in my backyard slash will my
food needs be met I don't know I think
food will be okay for a while you should
have a gun but food will be okay for a
while
I think the supply chain will get
disrupted for things like medicine and
[ __ ] that comes from supplies from China
but I think food you know will be okay
okay Nathan Hager thanks for the super
chat as a nice super chat what's the
best cabinet position for Oscar to
thriven if Oscar Oscar would probably be
good at sack a secretary of defense or
secretary of the Treasury because he's
one he always he wants to invade other
countries and he also wants to loot the
Treasury Joseph Kennedy are miss Cruz
also said that he wants to get in
banking and take it away from those
people
and I don't know again he refused to
elaborate Joseph Kennedy I already said
thank you but I was trying to ask if
dairy barn is ahead of its time
dairy barn you mean the drive-thru thing
on Long Island where you can get milk
and cigarettes iced tea yeah it's been
it's of course Brian Odegard ask my
guess is that Ben Affleck is not
drinking lots of water right now I'm in
downtown Seattle tumbleweeds yeah I
don't know what the first one if that
means that Ben asked I don't know what
he said but yeah to Seattle's [ __ ] we
said that Seattle's in real trouble
Bob Lyman and I you know I've wanted to
feel more bad for them but I've never
liked the Pacific Northwest I don't but
I love salmon but I don't like the
people
Bob Lyman asks did you know speed
Levitch
and impressions yeah Timmy speed Levitch
I think I reached out to him he was a
dude he has this amazing documentary
called the cruise and he's this amazing
[ __ ] poor guy in New York City who
gave this amazing tour of New York and
he used to give tours of Grand Central
Station at rush hour which was the
coolest [ __ ] idea ever like he'd walk
people in wild people just here's a
[ __ ] good dude I think I'm mad I
think we I think we might have spoke
briefly over in the Internet online
facebook Messenger back in the day um I
don't know that we ever met in person we
might have met very briefly in person I
know he did comedy but he never did it
when I did it hmm we never saw each
other doing comedy but any we did some
type of comedy put the crews if you want
to watch a [ __ ] great documentary
about New York City tour guides the
cruise is the best speed Levitch is like
za like even though I did tours I would
say he's like za if there was one tour
guide in New York City that's the guy
like he's the guy I never wanted to be
the guy I want to be like the funny you
know but he's like his tours are up were
amazing Dustin Dumas I sent you messages
out my experience with Illuminati wanted
to do interview I was selected Dustin
Dustin I got the message ID what do you
mean what Saudi Arabia they're trying to
that you want to show me some email
address Dustin what are you even saying
Dustin I who cares destructor you Dustin
what what are we getting at here what
kind of we're running
magical apps you and you're talking
about that somebody say an email so what
I mean Dustin who cares you the
government tries to recruit a lot of
people go work for them for ten years
then have something to say [ __ ] doing
destructor o asks Tim I work for the
Santa sanitation department in a rich
town in Massachusetts smart move good
job right now I'm working shut down or
not thanks for the last shout out
bastard radio thank you very much yeah
that's me Lois and Nick it was gonna be
a thing and then Lois you know did Lois
did Lois dead over it's serious he went
with the wood to the meeting without me
and neck NW asked how was the ride in
Rogen's Tesla um it's a great car it
goes very very fast Wow William lively
as soon as a giant perch at a house box
punjah box watch ient ten grands kidding
Thank You William you will ship the
vaccine you would have the vaccine keep
going
what is the chance Harvey Weinstein
engineered Co vid to sleep with my wife
pig for president uh uh thank you uh
very little sir I think Harvey's had
much better than your old lady okay Roxy
B asks do you think Hillary will win the
popular vote again in 2020 that's a good
question
yes
okay let me get to some more here okay
Tim do you think AOC can pull off a
Pyrrhic victory and conquer climate
change before the world ends in May no I
don't think she has any interest in it I
think she likes being on the covers of
magazines
yeah who's by Tim picking as his VP
Kamala Harris or Elizabeth Warren
wouldn't that be great if Elizabeth
Warren walked out there that snake
wouldn't be great
warrants you know you gotta respect
Warren a little bit because she's a real
snake
and I don't mean respect her in the way
that like I respect my daddy I mean like
just look at it like a game and you go
wow what a real snake yeah didn't
endorse Bernie went on SNL Biden you
know stayed in you know it might be
might be her but I think he's gonna go
Kamala Harris cuz cuz she's a cop
okay Ryan asks oh he's a realtor and
need to him here we go a realtor yeah
here we go how did you just say that you
say router realtor realtor realtor I
said realtor I'm no don't do this weird
Texas [ __ ] you'll be out of here
I'm a realtor I'm a realtor in
California no you're not should I should
I stay optimistic the market will bounce
back or should I smother my family in
their sleep homes
yeah we're pens yeah where do you sell
homes certain market ain't coming back
okay Beebe asks do you think AOC can
pull off oh I read that one hold on yeah
trying to catch up here guys sorry
Shannon Conway asked the world has
burned only Long Island was immune what
does the new world look like um what
does a new world look like after what
Long Island burns always said the world
has burned only Long Island was immune
what does the new world look like oh
great sandwiches and the worst people
the best sandwiches and the worst people
that should be on the sign going into
Long Island yeah we have the best
sandwiches and the worst people
I mean genuinely my friend's parents are
like why should I quarantine and people
like it's ridiculous to stay home just
use
pure al they're literally telling each
other that not only that it's ridiculous
idea of quarantine is ridiculous
why is there no toilet paper ziti comedy
asks I don't understand you know people
along island alike I
we've only had 49 deaths from this flu
do you know how many pdfs we've had from
black people that's what they're saying
I'm Long Island right now ziti comedy
says I live in Detroit reason enough
good move and I have been battling
chronic pancreatitis for the last year
and my life has gone to hell do I end it
sorry to hear that no don't end it it's
gonna we'll watch everyone else end it
you get to watch you you are the one
that gets to watch it could go bad for
everyone else now stick around stick
around it's only gonna get worse and I'm
sorry about that by the way
yes sir wants to know if it will survive
no people that gray tend to survive yeah
good people that are like you know work
out and have families tend to die Joey
visit cast tell Brad Garris he's a
ginger ho don't know that is yeah who is
that I have no idea Brad Garrett I don't
know him from Everybody Loves Raymond
he's not redheaded okay new super chat
in Alex Hilde Lee how much would it take
for a hard-r f-bomb on live stream and
name to price to brutally murder been on
the same live stream no particular order
no I'm not murdering Ben or saying the
n-word
there's no that's not no amount of money
to murder Ben let's say the n-word
William lively again thank you buddy my
wife heard your answer can I borrow $95
okay because he gave us a hundred
earlier I guess oh that's funny well she
you know listen what do you want me to
do Harvey wants he's got the pick of the
litter it's gonna be knocking on your
door it's quite a thought rotor your
woman okay Frank of Franco says what do
you think of the social justice warrior
Jamila Jamil hashtag climate sexist you
know what I don't know herself Akana
knows her and likes her as a person I I
mean I don't [ __ ] now Jamila Jim
whatever yeah I know I mean she's some
actress I mean what do I know about her
I don't know I'm sure me and her aren't
getting along
what are you talking about Q star have
you ever thought why have you here we go
have you ever done a bring her show was
it as sad as they seem yes I did one the
second show on comedy dude was a bringer
and then I decided never to do it again
because I came from the world of
subprime mortgage people or hucksters
and I understood that the people that
produced bringer shows were talentless
hucksters that were trying to get
themselves stage time by you know
figuring out a way to guarantee that the
club had seats filled that night and
what they did is they went to younger
comedians who didn't know better and got
them to bring their friends so I
realized that pretty soon you know there
are people that do them for years and
don't quite get it
and those people I wonder I worry about
because you know obviously there's a
problem there and obviously look at
who's producing the show for the most
part it's goons
Roxy B do you think us Bernie bros will
vote for Trump again in 2020 I don't
know what you'll do
I don't I mean I don't I don't know what
you'll do
I don't care I mean I think that that's
a small I mean that's probably small
contingent of people you know that are
gonna go from I mean it might not be
that small but okay totally and
different thanks for the super chat says
watching Brendon special during in times
just to push over the edge and end it
faster okay okay you don't like Brandon
we get it we're okay ka
says future podcast topic event 201 held
by bill gates at John Hopkins specified
topic of discussion equals he just
wanted to let everyone know but first
I'm trying to understand like what what
the thought process is there like he's
just gonna come out and tell everybody
like alright we're gonna have corona now
I mean he's he's been warning he's been
banging that alarm about pandemics for
like a very long time and he's been
trying to get clean water and Africa
yeah I mean I guess you could just say
that like you know he will he's
telegraphing his desire I just don't I
again guys I don't understand what this
accomplishes for rich people to just
shut everything down and to have
potentially civil unrest and all that
stiii I don't understand that and I
don't think you guys logically if you're
not schizophrenic and that's a big if I
don't think you guys logically would
believe that this benefits rich people I
mean think about it do you would you
rather poor people at work earning
nothing and I love all these people are
like they don't want us to earn money
that's why they're doing this you don't
earn money you don't look at the
inequality you don't earn really that
much money they don't want us to earn
money that's why they don't want me to
work at Lilly Flanagan yeah you don't
earn money but they want you occupy they
want you earning something they don't
[ __ ] meet like what do you guys think
the end game is in your lurid fantasy
imaginations of what these people want
what do you think they want you think
they just want you think they just want
to depopulate the whole earth who's
gonna bring them their food who's gonna
pick the berries they put on their
cereal automations not ready to take
over yet maybe in a few years there will
be I mean guys you gotta get a little
smarter than this you have to think a
little bit what's the endgame here to
get rid of you to get you in your house
why they all never come in contact with
you in their life I don't understand
help me understand well the end game is
fear it's fear for what oh cares you I
don't understand like what else what
else could the end game here be what
would they want the world to look like
if it if they don't look at the world as
it is
what would they want the world to look
like I don't understand overrun
hospitals and a plague and I mean I
don't understand how this benefits them
long-term wouldn't they just like to
stay billionaires and just not give a
[ __ ] about you the way they've not been
giving a [ __ ] about you you've presented
no threat to their power ever you're not
worried they're not nervous they don't
care so why would they actually drive
the system like you could say that they
drove it to the brink of collapse
because they are sociopaths who don't
value human life and they don't care and
that's true but that's also us we don't
give a [ __ ] about public health we
idolize people like Trump and ALC
because they're fun to look at and watch
we tell scientists to shut the [ __ ] up
we don't care about through the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
we don't even know what the [ __ ] that is
it's not sexy and fun and and then this
[ __ ] happens you're like oh [ __ ] but I
mean nothing you want that answer you
want some [ __ ] answer about da no
it's a military operation and Trump's
really trying to like you know arrest
Hillary and that's what this whole eight
guys it's not real I mean when this Q
cult like when that punctured when none
of this [ __ ] happens or it does happen
in it's hilarious cuz I'll be laughing
so hard if it happens but let's say it
won't let's say Trump doesn't go and
arrest all the other presidents like we
all believe he's doing well at what
point will any of you go oh good so yeah
I guess it wasn't that way I guess it
wasn't the way that I thought it was and
I think you guys think that by figuring
this [ __ ] out you're like in the know
you're like in the I I'm in the now
you're not in the now you're not in the
same way so you don't like Brenda Chavez
comedy they don't go repossess his
Lamborghini because you don't like his
can't lick it no one cares this is the
game world playing and it's like you
don't have to play it you could call it
out from being [ __ ] fine but you
know it's just like I just don't
understand where how you come to these
conclusions that are like completely
irrational then it's like no there's
Bill Gates did this this is a Bill Gates
production the virus
clever man huh keep calling sorry go
listen to the magical thinking episode
on patreon if you want to hear more
about that yeah those are great up ok
dare Crawford says do you think idiots
with guns will refuse the inevitable
quarantine resulting in chaos
why wouldn't they you know okay sorry I
know we're behind 12 behind now hold on
tada
okay not getting questions answered okay
Adam ask Dylan Ratigan said today on
Jimmy doors show that we're going to
have you bi and possibly Medicare for
all in the coming weeks what do you
think um great yeah that'd be great
great okay proto no no I know I want the
market to figure right proto no ass I
mean these retards by the way the Fox
News conservative morons like the
pro-business people I mean they're
they're done now their times done yeah
they're done the guys are just pimp
cobbler cobbler I mean they're it's over
now with the futures gonna look more
socialist whether you like it or not
just what it is it's not gonna be full
read you know Marxism but it's gotta be
more social there's just yeah I think
we're gonna look at this in big [ __ ]
people need access to health care yeah
hundred percent proto no asks all right
Tim the world's ending and has been for
years are you optimistic for the next
world and can you tell an underrated
joke of yours you like um am i
optimistic for the next world no unless
it's free of people um a joke that I
underrated joke that I like um yeah a
kid that was this was from the one of
the select a second a third joke I wrote
a kid who was the Latin Kings found out
a kid was gay when he was getting jumped
in to their gang and they beat him up
and I feel very bad about that I'm like
I wonder how they found out that he was
gay and I was like well if you're if
you're trying to get into the Latin
Kings moral of story is don't ask to be
danced in
you're trying if you're trying to get
into the Latin Kings don't ask to be
danced in okay dr. dr. Chuck is it worth
breaking mister worth breaking a six-day
streak of not going outside and risking
exposure to the plague to buy a handgun
I've never owned a gun in my life I mean
it depends where you live and how
eminent you think the danger is it's not
a bad idea to have a handgun you're not
gonna be expanding I don't know it also
depends how many people you're gonna
come in contact with now do you have a
compromised immune system are you you
know I don't know okay Timmy Lane says
my roommate Big Tuna has a cough but
swears it's not Corona should he or I
sleep in the hall I mean everybody's
gonna get this what are you gonna do
river styxx says what should you ask
Hillary if she would do your podcast she
has to answer all questions in truth
what would I ask Hillary if she had to
answer all questions and truth how many
deaths have you arranged personal I'm
curious is it like five or is it like
forty hey Ben what's the worst city in
US and why is it Arlington Texas
Arlington does suck what would you say
the worst city in in the u.s. is you
Tim's traveled more is better
I've lived in like West Texas in
California that's it worst city in the
u.s. I'll tell you one that I really
don't like Bridgeport Connecticut
it's de-industrialized yeah it's just a
health scare yeah it's just you know the
factories moved it's all over okay
Andrew Liston says if you could be
quarantined with any world leader
throughout all of history who would it
be and why world leaders throughout all
of history
I mean Stalin seems kind of fun you know
as long as like he's easy paranoid he'd
probably kill me I mean but you know I
don't know
Lincoln's interesting he was gay yeah I
think I don't know I mean it's a good
question yeah I don't I don't you know
world leader Christ if he exists him
yeah or the Romans killed Christ I don't
know
Brad Garris who dat that's a reference
to I guess doing a bit back yeah that's
a good that's a good one guys
whatever keeps you add one whatever
keeps you going right okay here we go
trying to catch up here whatever makes
you happy but at the end whatever makes
you happy folks I'll tell you another
thing I think's coming I think those
drive-through testing centers pretty
soon you're gonna see like real issues
at the drive-through testing centers
it's kind of gonna be like popeyes
chicken sandwich time except it's a
corona test mm-hmm so the fists are
gonna fly yeah and people are gonna get
real angry with each other my manager
who lives in New York City told me that
you cannot get toilet paper you can get
any food you want in New York you can
get Sullivan but who cares right just go
don't you say just take a [ __ ] and go in
the shower yeah who cares get a bidet
online or something you know do you have
of the day I don't yeah we don't have
one either but I'm just saying if you
had to you could just go to the shower
yeah I'm not saying it's not you know
just is what it is
Nathan thinks says they never they say
never waste a good crisis what a pad a
pad and a pen for what do you just have
yeah well no I'll get you a pad what
legislation are they going to pass to
curb more of our freedoms Rahm Emanuel
said that never
I don't know what legislation comes out
of this I mean it really depends on how
bad the economic fallout is you know I
mean what freedoms you have left I mean
it this you know I mean like I mean
anything here's what they'll do anything
that they couldn't constitutionally do
before this they'll they'll make sure
that it's in the constitution out when
they can mandate that you know you what
share and you living room you sit it I
don't know just you know after
coronavirus settles will you please come
to the UK for a live show yeah we're
gonna do so Theatre in London I wanted
to do it this summer I was planning to
come and do it this summer q star says
opinion on re dosing Bert with MDMA in
front of his kids I mean not right I
don't think that was a good thing to do
91 okie thanks for the super chat will
you be low at skank fest even cares it's
still about re dosing partly it's the
end of the world and this is what these
people care about podcasters drug enjoy
the world and this is what you're
talking about this person says I feel
bad for Corona that it's gonna have to
enter many of you it's not all gonna be
address Elba it's gonna be gonna you're
gonna be in a lot of nobody's noses keep
going will you be low at skank fest I'm
a hot tall twink Derek Murphy I bet
you're not I bet you're not a hot tall
twink Derek Murphy we can't type or
spell yeah and there is no scam well I
blow you at the festival that's not
coming sure yeah sounds good
thanks for the super truth in he says
rank the members of million-dollar
extreme Sam ah who's a trouble you're
one Nick Rock refer I think he's two for
me and then Charles Carroll
yeah his terms are funny yeah yeah yeah
terms of funny I think Sam and then the
dick and then the other one Charles okay
let's see it's a great shot I mean they
were all very funny but if you have to
rank them deliverance iske orders
residents to stay inside saw that yeah
they have a gun sales
ah Dylan Amon Dylan bragdon thanks for
the super chat thanks for the good
content and podcast you and Ben are
awesome thank you okay have a gun but
it's like if it gets to that and it
might man is it gonna be a problem
because you know if it gets to that it
means that the failure the failures are
becoming you know insurmountable like
there there there yeah it's not a bad
idea to have protection at all but like
there's some [ __ ] there's some ugly
stuff happening Bokke asks would you
have saved Epstein from being murdered
if you could um yes because I'd want
I'd want other people that he was
associated with to go to jail okay we're
at an hour now so we're gonna answer the
rest of these questions yeah all right
Tim my DN drugs are doing fine so
everyone stock up before they shut down
USPS got it disinfect everything though
just in case stay safe okay I don't know
I don't what's my D in drugs okay hold
on we're reading the rest of them Alex
Haley
thanks for the super chat this virus
jumped to human around the beginning of
November do you think this virus was
already in u.s. prior to two weeks ago
and running NASA most cases would have
been passed off as flu yes 100% 100%
Andrew bhakta I believe you could very
successfully prover beyond dr. drew I
mean hopefully it's up to him but we're
not right now I mean he might have me
Skype in hit him op tweet him okay let
me make sure I was just on I don't want
to tell them but all right that
something's coming out that I did
oh yeah in April okay do making sure we
answered all the questions of people
that paid Alex sent the question did he
pay Steinberg yeah Steinberg sent a car
I didn't see him
you probably asked a free question I'm
gonna say what's your name did you pay
oh he paid do we answer it already quick
flick FX how much did he pay though I
think I saw that but he paid like 2
bucks I'm gonna ask him what he paid
little Alex two dollars yeah I didn't I
skipped right over I see the - I just
keep scrolling you know
we skip - okay we got two left here I
believe was the last book you've read
Tim last book I read was
it's a trump one uh the one that came
out fire and fury yeah I think that's
the name of it was a trump one that came
out no no no it's a recent one it's not
fire and sure it's it's one I can't
think of the name but it's the Trump one
that came out in the last six months I
forget the name of it or it was it but
it came out recently came out like two
months ago and I read that um I think
the wit and wisdom of Donald Trump know
the case of Trump
are very stable genius those are the
most popular ones yeah I can't I can't
remember what it was I'm trying to think
then I read some Stan and wrote I jump
around we face unique pages I read
recently I read of America the Pharaoh
so after the farewell tour Chris Hedges
okay Derek Crawford asked we face unique
problems since our pop is is armed are
you worried about civil unrest I think
Alex said he asked how Oscar was doing
during Corona
I mean Oscar is corona is the pot is
civil unrest cuz we have an armed
population
I think civil unrest comes down and how
bad it gets are they able we got to open
up for shot we got to open for business
again in a few months we got to open up
in eight weeks again partially we can't
not I mean I know it's gonna be tough
but there's just not really too many
other options Andrew asks I hope most
people aren't affected by the corona
virus but don't you think most of them
deserve at least chlamydia yes okay
these are the last two questions were
answering right yes - okay here we go
here we go okay Alex Haley says it's
pronounced Hildy not Hilde Lee okay also
Ilyn pronounced also Illinois has not
banned the sale of guns or booze I just
bought a few more guns today but it's
coming okay no what did anyone say that
they banned the sale of guns arboost no
I don't think we said that so thank you
but thanks for the super chat deagles
2970 says will you ever dip back into
the franklin scandal what do you mean
get back into it I don't understand
talk about it again I've done four
episodes four whole hour-long episodes
on it we have since we have Johnny Gosch
is mother and the [ __ ] director of
the film who took Johnny when we've had
Nick Bryant three [ __ ] times didn't
mean ray have talked about it I mean at
a certain point there's no new info
there's not really I wanted to get
Alicia I want on the show who was one of
the victims of the Franklin scandal I
wanted to get her on the show me and Ben
we're gonna go down there I mean that
all could still happen I mean it's just
it right now we're in a pandemic I might
go to the patreon it's all there all in
the patreon there's not a lot of [ __ ] in
the patreon a lot of it keep your heads
about you folks keep your wits about you
keep pumping the jewels keep selling the
jewels knock on the door
get in there tell him yours tell him
your okay tell him you're fine even if
you're coughing a little bit it's okay
don't take ibuprofen if you have a flu
take acetaminophen French authorities
have come out and said ibuprofen being
the anti-inflammatory it is your body's
got to fight this thing your immune
system you gotta fight this thing so you
can't just keep cheating with ibuprofen
acetaminophen I'll bring down a flow
I don't think I have a fever I know the
kind of can you tell I can I can tell
when you're sick you've been sick you
seem better I never do that can you tell
if I have a fever no you're fine just
feels like you got out of the shower all
right folks
try to stay focused I know it's tough
out there I know many of you are gonna
want to start doing creative things in
your house cut it out
many of you were gonna start to try it
maybe you're like you know maybe I have
a talent you don't okay you know I don't
know what to tell you but don't do that
don't cut that [ __ ] out now Tim Dylan
show we're going hard yes this was late
it was late cuz Ben Ben came lake's he
doesn't care about you he doesn't care
about the East Coast people ask why it's
so late we're gonna try to do these
during the week at an earlier time yeah
you know Ben can get here a little
earlier um until he's not allowed to
come anymore you'll always be I think
hopefully you'll always be allowed to
come yeah you know I'll just have to
shoot my way here no I think you'll just
say this is like your job or you could
say you're going out for food and just
come here I don't know listen I'll cross
that bridge when we come to it we could
be coming to it quickly
we could pretend you're really sick and
I'm taking care of you I mean who knows
but let's just let's hopefully hopefully
that's not an issue hopefully I don't
have to flee LA hopefully we all don't
have to flee LA get out of here go to
the country because it's coming
everywhere folks it's gonna come
everywhere every Creek and crevice you
know alright last question mr. frost Tim
any sales tips and tricks of the trade
loved your podcast with Joey Diaz thank
you yeah look him in the eye
yell get a little loud hello
don't get too loud but speak like you're
presenting something look him in the eye
make him understand that you're selling
them an experience you're changing their
life for the better it's not just about
jewels it's about love they have
experienced enough love people buy
things because they're unloved
I want a sneaker no one loves me I don't
get enough love I want this bag of
heroin I don't get enough love I wonder
if in and out is still open people buy
things because they're unloved be their
lover love them with your eyes in your
mouth love them with the words you say
in the pictures you paint of the future
people don't buy they buy because they
want love you be the love you understand
that I'm the best sales trainer in
America because I'll tell you why people
buy things because they think it'll
complete them
it'll fill the hole they have in their
hearts in their head ice a cosmic joke
we're born alone and die alone it's just
what it is in every relationship someone
likes someone else more there's always
somebody there's always an odd man out
there's always somebody wandering the
streets Alyssa that's showing the
streets of London it's a great song and
you tell me you're lonely and for you
the Sun don't shine let me take you by
the hand I'll lead you through the
streets of London that's your job your
job is to make people feel warm and
gooey inside like there's a future and
that there's a hope and you put that
diamond and it's not gonna be a diamond
but you put that jewel in their hand and
then when they look at that glittering
jewel they know that you just for that
moment love them do you understand
that's what it's about
you
good luck out there be good to each
other and be good to yourselves
patreon.com Tim Dylan show to tears 20
and 5 we know it's rough out there 5 is
fine you get one extra episode every
week and how many archives 145 145 hours
of archived content plus 30 bonus
episodes plus 30 bonus episodes oh so
wait so why are you we not adding them
together like the bonus in the archives
well in terms with the archives that
there behind it well yeah I guess so 145
archives of the old show and then 30 new
bonus episode a he'd been doing great
you know I consider that I say I call
them all archives and I say 30 plus 145
175 175 episode 175 hours of content
more really really more cuz it multi
hour shows probably all close to close
to 200 hours of content for five dollars
a month interviews with some really
amazing people about conspiracies actual
real conspiracies things that are
happening now Bill Gates poison your
turkey sandwich like actual [ __ ] that
they're gonna [ __ ] do I don't know if
they're lying about this virus in the
sense it could be a bio weapon but I'm
pretty sure that there's nobody just
invented this nobody invented this to
tank everything just so they could do a
social experiment to see if they can get
Americans to sit on the couch and eat
guess what we're all pretty certain that
we can do that I mean can you imagine
like some meeting of the Bilderberg
Group they're like hey let's release a
virus it'll only really kill 3 million
be like not nearly enough to assuage any
of the problems but you know all these
all these people that took our bags from
the airport I'd like them home with
their families that's know they want you
sweating in front of them working ok
they want to know when the patreon is
going live we're gonna record it after
this we're gonna record it at we're
going to record it after - should we
just put it up tonight what the patreon
or tomorrow we could put the patreon up
tonight
we can put the patron up today early and
the were we gonna do this so we're gonna
leave this on YouTube yeah so I'm gonna
make a link for this it's gonna be
unlisted it's gonna be on the patreon if
you're on the page no I mean I will just
leave it on you they're not getting to
know I know it's on YouTube but I'll
leave it oh you just want to leave this
up for the public here's the deal this
is either gonna be the patreon episode
or we're gonna just leave this up for
the public and do another page right
after that okay this just can just be a
public episode yeah so we're gonna leave
this up and then we will obviously
people getting upset about the phone
conversation on the patreon so we're not
gonna do any phone conversations until
we figure out a way to get better
quality audio the problem is you know
some of the audio is fine quality but
some of it is it really depends a lot on
the Wi-Fi on the other end and what's
going on on the other end and you know
it's like what are you gonna [ __ ] do
and we know to use discord but a lot of
people don't know how to download the
app yeah we're gonna we're gonna do that
it's all coming it's all it's all gonna
be right about the time Society falls
off a cliff we're gonna have everything
that we need all right thanks everybody
for participating goodbye